Traductor: Lily María Bello Sánchez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Me dijeron: "piensa en una idea que
hable sobre pasar tus límites,
pasar las barreras de la vida,
y además, impactar
positivamente en el mundo.
Y yo dije: "Ok".
"Ok, ok, lo voy a pensar"
Pero, lamentablemente no es tan fácil
como subir y darles un tip sencillo, ¿no?
¡Ay! Hagan esto, punto.
Ahí está, ¿no?
Creo que nada de nuestro
exterior nos puede funcionar
para realmente sobrepasar
nuestros límites.
Creo que todo viene desde el interior.
Y obviamente todos tienen que hablar
desde su experiencia, desde sus vivencias.
Y por eso es que hoy
voy a hablarles un poquito de mí.
Ok, yo creo que todos tenemos
vallas que pasar.
A diferentes niveles, en diferentes
alturas y diferentes dificultades.
Pero, para mí, ninguna es
imposible de saltar.
Hoy miro hacia atrás y
no me creo lo que he logrado.
Pero, luego recuerdo que fui yo
quien lo hice y lo creo.
Me choca esta pregunta:
¿Cómo te ves en 5 o 10 años?
Si le preguntaras a la Yoss
de hace 5 años cómo se veía,
pues no tenía ni idea
que iba a contestar.
Y a la edad de 10 menos,
apenas empezaba a existir Youtube.
O sea, esta pregunta es imposible
de contestar.
Nadie es adivino del futuro.
Además, yo creo que proyectar tus metas
a tan largo plazo es contraproducente.
¿Por qué?
Porque tienes que enfocarlas
en el hoy, en el ahorita,
en tu presente o tu futuro inmediato.
Cuando tenemos 18 años, la sociedad
nos obliga, por no decir que nos invita,
a estudiar una carrera.
Y es algo horrible, porque
a los 18 años eres inmaduro,
no sabes que quieres de la vida,
te gustan dos o tres personas
al mismo tiempo.
No tienes ni idea.
Y ahí estás tú, aventándote
por el tobogán de la vida,
cruzando los dedos, rezando,
esperando que hayas tomado
la mejor decisión
de escoger la carrera que más te late.
Los que no sabemos que estudiar,
generalmente estudiamos comunicación.
Porque en comunicación
ves todo y ves nada.
Es chistoso porque todos los que
estaban en mi generación,
pues se dedican a cosas diferentes
hoy en día.
Yo, soy creadora de contenido.
Uno de mis mejores amigos es chef.
Otra amiga trabaja en Pemex.
Y pues así cada quién es diferente.
La mayoría acaban
en agencias de publicidad.
Entonces yo me pregunto:
¿por qué demonios no
estudiaron publicidad?
Pero bueno, eso ya es otra historia.
La verdad es que yo quería estudiar cine.
No pude hacerlo porque mis papas no tenían
el dinero para pagarme esa carrera
Entonces, a diferencia todos mis demás
compañeros de la carrera,
yo sí sabía que quería.
La mayoría no tenía ni idea.
Eran así como pues estudié comunicación
porque eh, no sé,
me gusta comunicar.
Ah, oralé, ¿no? pues chido.
Yo sabía que me gustaban los medios.
Desde muy chiquita empecé
a hacer televisión.
Y soñaba con ser locutora de radio.
Me encantaban las películas.
Yo siempre tuve muy claro
que era lo que quería.
Mi sueño era ser locutora de radio
y estar en los medios.
Eso era lo que diferenciaba a mis
compañeros conmigo.
El problema es que en
la carrera de comunicación,
la radio te la dan
hasta los últimos semestres.
Entonces, no me iba a quedar
con los brazos cruzados,
esperando pues a ver
en qué momento me iban a enseñar
lo que realmente quería saber.
¿Qué hice?
Crucé el límite.
Me puse las pilas,
empecé a buscar chambitas.
Y así es como llegué a conseguir
mi primer trabajo a los 19 años.
Que es un programa de televisión,
Más bien, que fue un programa
de televisión.
Que se llamaba pulpo SA de CV.
En este trabajo, me ofrecieron
15000 pesos mensuales.
Era full-time.
Entonces, tenía que
renunciar a mi carrera.
Lo hice.
Por supuesto, 15 000 pesos para mí
en ese entonces era guau.
Nunca he ganado eso.
Y me pagaban por ser conductora.
Claro, no nada más fui conductora.
Era la productora,
era la que checaba edición,
la que conseguía locaciones,
la que conseguía entrevistas.
Es más, tenía que editar los guiones
porque el guionista era
tan descarado y tan malo
que copiaba las cosas
de Wikipedia, copy y paste.
Y les dejaba el editar entre paréntesis.
Entonces, pues, al final era mi imagen,
y yo tenía que estar modificando
todos los guiones.
Ahora que si me preguntas
si valían 15 000 pesos
todo lo que yo hacía,
la verdad es que no, no lo valía.
Pero, lo valió porque aprendí mucho.
Por eso dicen, que la práctica
hace al maestro y no la escuela.
¡Ojo! No estoy diciendo que
no estudien la carrera, bla bla.
Estoy hablando desde
mi experiencia para mí cómo fue.
Hice dos años y medio de carrera.
Y mi carrera, siguió pero en el trabajo.
Como todo principio tiene su fin.
Pues, se acabó mi programa.
Y estuvo muy triste,
me deprimí muchísimo, lloré.
Para mí, se había acabado el mundo.
Me despidieron, no porque
yo haya hecho algo malo,
sino porque cambiaron la programación,
y pues me dijeron adiós.
Entonces, pues yo era muy chavita y
pensaba que se estaba acabando el mundo.
Pero, todavía no aprendía que
la vida es cambiante.
Y ahí me tienes a mi deprimida,
sin trabajo, sin carrera,
y con un perrito bebé nuevo que
mantener porque se me hizo fácil.
¿Qué hice?
Me puse las pilas, me puse a
buscar cosas.
Empecé a hacer miles de castings,
de los cuales de miles
también me rechazaron.
Me metí a cursos de cosas
que a mi me gustaban;
cursos de locución, cursos de doblaje,
cursos de actuación.
Y finalmente, vi esta oportunidad de
empezar a hacer vídeos en una plataforma.
Y dije; ok, ¡guau!, esto es algo
que ya he hecho anteriormente,
como en la televisión, pero, esto va a ser
100% mi responsabilidad.
Nadie me va a decir;
"Está bien, está mal"
"Tienes que decir esto, o léete
este guión de Wikipedia", ¿no?
Esto va a ser mi onda.
Y para mí era un gran reto
para mi creatividad,
para mi persona, para todo.
Y dije, orale, lo voy a empezar a hacer.
La realidad es que yo tenía en mente
que si yo hacía algo bien ahí,
pues me iban a jalar de la tele,
me iban a jalar de la radio,
me iban a jalar de otros lados.
Y sí, tenía razón.
Me empezaron a jalar de
diferentes televisoras.
Empecé a hacer unitarios, que son
como la rosa de Guadalupe y esas cosas.
Nunca estuve en la rosa. Tranquilos.
Ya sé que oso. Pero,
en ese momento, aprendí mucho.
Era algo muy cool.
Y llegó el trabajo de mis sueños.
Así es, llegué a ser locutora de radio.
Quería sacar provecho a esta voz,
sexy y ronca que tengo.
Y fue mi primer trabajo godín como tal.
El primer trabajo en una empresa
donde es como old-school.
donde todo es muy limitado,
donde tienes que hacer horas nalgas
Y no horas de calidad.
Y empecé a tener muchos choques mentales.
Empecé a sufrir por primera vez
ataques de ansiedad.
Y yo decía: ¡Guau!.
O sea mi mundo colapsó.
¿Cómo es posible?
Tenía el trabajo de mis sueños,
siempre soñé ser locutora,
trabajaba en la tele,
me invitaban a conducir
los juegos olímpicos, el súper bowl,
tenía protagónicos en unitarios,
hacía todo lo que yo quería,
y era infeliz.
Tenía ataques de ansiedad.
Y me di cuenta ahí que no siempre
lo que sueñas es lo que verdad quieres.
Y eso es algo muy difícil de aceptar
porque te imaginaste
toda tu vida en tal cosa,
y de repente llegas y dices pues no.
¿Qué pasó ahí? Que me limitó
Me limitó como nunca
me había limitado ese trabajo.
Era un empresa que no me dejaba crecer.
Me acuerdo perfecto cuando renuncié
di la gracias y le dije : "Perdón pero
aquí no me dejan crecer."
"Me están limitando."
Y entonces me salí, renuncié
y empecé a enfocarme a lo que
en verdad tenía que enfocarme.
En cosas que tenían importancia.
Empecé a ser libre, encontré libertad.
Libertad de creatividad,
libertad de tiempo,
libertad de hacer lo que yo quisiera.
Y esa libertad, me dio evolución.
Esa libertad hizo que
yo avanzara, que todo fluyera.
Empecé a enfocarme
en mis vídeos, en mi cosas.
A la gente le empezó a gustar.
Fluyó y así fui creciendo paulatinamente.
Todo fue avanzando, todo muy bonito.
Obviamente, enfocándome en
mis habilidades,
porque acuérdensen que
el que mucho abarca poco aprieta
como la carrera de comunicación.
Hay gente que de repente dice:
"No pues quiero hacer esto, y esto..."
Sí, pero espérate ¿no?
Hay que enfocarse un poquito.
No hay mejor manera que autoobservarse.
Pero, objetivamente, ¿no?
Porque uno se puede echar muchas flores,
pero hay que ser objetivos.
De repente, hay que salirnos un pocos
de este cuerpo y vernos,
y decir: Ok, ¿para qué soy buena?
¿qué se me da?
En mi caso, pues yo vi que era
muy buena desenvolviéndome,
no me daba pena la cámara,
era muy movida,
se me daba la onda de producir.
O sea empecé a ver mis habilidades,
y sobre eso me fui enfocando
y las fui desarrollando.
Porque a veces hay gente que no sé
se le metió la idea a la cabeza
y conozco a muchos que dicen:
"Quiero ser actor, quiero ser actriz."
Pero, nadie les dijo que mal son
actuando, lo hacen muy mal.
Y aún peor, que nadie les dice,
no se dan cuenta ellos solos.
Ellos solos no pueden autoobservarse
y decir: "Ok, no se me da,
no tengo ese talento."
Entonces, si es muy importante
encontrar tus habilidades,
encontrar tus talentos,
y sobre eso enfocarte.
No querer acaparar todo.
Y no querer ser una persona empedernida,
de no es yo que dije que quería ser actor,
y entonces voy a ser actor.
Sí, pero, en realidad ¿traes el talento?
Y no importa que talento tengas,
puede que cantes muy bonito,
puede que actúes padrisímo,
pero también si no lo pones en práctica,
no te sirve.
Pónganse a prueba, eso es lo que yo les
vengo a decir el día de hoy.
Pónganse a prueba, lo que Uds. tienen
en mente y lo que sueñan,
Ok, ahí está, háganlo, inténtenlo.
Yo quería ser locutora, lo intenté,
lo busqué, lo soñé, y lo logré.
Después, me di cuenta que
no era lo que yo quería,
que no era realmente lo que
a mi me funcionaba.
Pero, lo hice.
Así que, trabajando
en el presente, en el hoy,
dando lo mejor de tí día a día,
haciendo las cosas de la manera
más inteligente posible,
para saber si donde estás
sembrando semillas,
realmente está dando frutos.
Y también, siendo
lo suficientemente inteligente
para saber si eso te está limitando.
Y saberlo soltar, y seguir por el camino
donde fluye y donde vas evolucionando.
Es como solito va fluyendo.
Tu vida va evolucionando y ya no te tienes
que preocupar por el futuro hoy.
Ya no importa cómo te ves en cinco o en
diez años,
porque realmente lo que importa es hoy
y ya que pasaste más allá de tus límites
o de los que creías que eran tus límites.
Así que recuerda,
si haces bien las cosas hoy,
lo que venga mañana será mejor.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)